so we have a circle here and let's say
that we know that its circumference is
equal to 6 pi I'll write it unit
whatever our units happen to be let's
see if we can figure out given that its
circumference is 6 pi of these units
what is the area going to be equal to
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own and first
think about if you could figure out the
area for this particular circle and then
let's see if we can come up with a
formula for given any circumference can
we figure out the area and vice versa
all right now let's work through this
together the key here is to realize that
from circumference you can figure out
radius and then from radius you can
figure out area so we know that
circumference which is 6 pi so we know 6
pi is equal to 2 pi times our radius and
so what is the radius going to be so the
radius we're talking about that distance
well we can divide both sides by 2 pi so
let's do that
if we divide both sides by 2 pi to solve
for our what are we left with well we
have an R on the right hand side we have
R is equal to pi divided by pi that's
just 1 6 divided by 2 is 3 so we get
that our radius right over here is equal
to 3 units and then we can use the fact
that area is equal to PI R squared to
figure out the area this is going to be
equal to PI times 3 squared
I don't have to write parenthesis there
pi times 3 squared which is of course
going to be equal to 9 pi so for this
particular example when the
circumference is 6 pi units we're able
to figure out that the area this is
actually going to be 9 pi square units
or I could write units squared because
we're squaring the radius the radius is
3 units so you square that you get the
units squared now let's see if we can
come up with a general formula so we
know that circumference is equal to 2 PI
R and we know that
area area is equal to PI r-squared can
we come up with an expression or a
formula that relates directly between
circumference and area and I'll give you
a hint solve for you could solve for R
right over here and substitute back into
this equation or vice versa pause the
video see if you can do that alright so
let's do it over here let's solve for R
if we divide both sides by 2 pi do it
another color so if we divide both sides
by 2 pi and this is exactly what we did
up here what are we left with we're left
with on the right hand side R is equal
to C the circumference divided by 2 pi
the radius is equal to the circumference
over 2 pi and so when we're figuring out
the area area remember is equal to pi
times our radius squared but we know
that our radius could be written as
circumference divided by 2 pi so instead
of radius I'll write circumference over
2 pi remember we want to relate between
area and circumference and so what is
this going to be equal to we get area is
equal to PI times circumference squared
over 2 pi squared is 4 pi squared let's
see we have a PI or we would have if we
multiply this out we'd have a pi in the
numerator and a PI into the NAM or 2
PI's in the denominator being multiplied
so pi divided by pi squared is just 1
over pi and so there you have it area is
equal to circumference squared divided
by divided by 4 pi let me write that
down so this is a neat you don't tend to
learn this formula but it's cool that we
were able to derive it area is equal to
circumference squared over 4 pi and we
can go the other way around give it an
area how do we figure out circumference
we could just put the numbers in here or
you could just solve for C let's
multiply both sides by 4 pi let's
multiply both sides by 4 pi and if we do
that what do we get we would get 4 pi
times the area is
equal to our circumference squared and
then to solve for the circumference we
just take the square root of both sides
so you would get the square root of four
pi times the area is equal to our
circumference and you could simplify
this a little bit if you wanted you
could take the four out of the radical
but this is pretty neat how you can
relate circumference and area